[Musique]
bonjour je vais vous parler du film le
professionnel de Georges Lautner qui est
sorti le 21 octobre 1980 il est pour ma
part l'un des meilleurs films avec notre
cher acteur Jean-Paul Belmondo il a été
très critiqué pour le côté raciste du
film et également la caricature de la
tournure du scénario et pourtant il a eu
son fameux succès avec une apparition de
Robert Hossein fabuleuse ce film raconte
tout simplement l'histoire de Joss
Beaumont qui est
issu de l'élite de l'armée française il
est chargé d'exécuter le président de la
malagawi un contre ordre va tomber et
pour éviter de nuire au président parce
que ce fameux président est devenu un
ami d'État ils vont incarcéré
bon et lui-même va décider de
contre-attaquer et de réagir
différemment face à l'état français sa
manière et son approche est hyper
intéressante ce qui fait vraiment tout
le film nous sommes également Bercy tout
le long du film par une musique d'Ennio
Morricone très connue
et qui apporte une force mémorable à la
chute du film qui est également nommable
et qui donne toute cette puissance au
film et à cette réalisation je pense que
là on peut vraiment parler d'une ligne
rouge qui découle sur une chute
puissante émotionnelle et d'une beauté
en fait pure une réponse il y a un
retour alors cette musique donne
également tout ce sens pour moi à ce
coup de cœur et je vous laisse sur ces
quelques notes de musique
[Musique]